I know you know something
I'm sick of hearing from the painters
why did I stir up a beehive with that
one and you should hear the what they're
talking about how many hours they work
and their [ __ ] city of you you would
think that they're actually out there
fighting a war the way they are waxing
about what it's like to color in a
[ __ ] wall prop painter from the
mandalorian I did an episode of that
last season hey there bill my day job as
a prop painter for movies and TV that's
my day job of congratulations that's a
cool job I mainly specialize in weapons
I've worked on a bunch of stuff you may
recognize from Avengers better call Saul
Westworld these are all my vendors I
don't watch i watch everything else and
a lot of the weapons and droids for the
Mandalorian you might be a little stoked
to know I've made a lot of these things
while listening to the Monday morning
podcast as lucky as I have been to find
my way into having the honor to paint
some really cool stuff I started I
started out my painting career painting
houses in my college years I can't argue
with you that a majority of house
painters suck thank you validation
validation if you can compare it to
something like cooking painting houses
is like starting your cooking career at
a Denny's if you haven't moved on to a
better restaurant after a few years then
you're probably not going to do it
for the love of it or as a career choice
if you haven't moved on to industrial
painting cars murals or entertainment
then you're just doing it for the money
and you're most likely just trying to
bang jobs out then you're not doing and
not so much caring about the artistry
while painting another four walls some
off-white color all right that makes
sense so basically painting houses is
sort of the open mic of painting and
then you move on to more to like more
difficult stuff to paint right I'm
joking because I know that there's the
richer prize in George Carlin's of house
painters I'm [ __ ] joking people roll
alright and by the way is there anything
cooler than someone who paints cars
alright I think that's that's [ __ ]
amazing and actually you know come on
some of the some of the the graffiti
that the people who suck at painting
paint over you know what I mean do you
ever have guilt people who just paint
walls when you paint over graffiti do
you have a look at you have a stand back
and be like wow this this vandal is
actually better at what they do than I
am
you know as your paint drips down onto
these poor plants underneath the
graffiti in defense of painters they
can't hide their shitty work the way a
plumber can like whoever did my old ass
[ __ ] house
they can't hide they're like I had a I
had a guy coming over looking at the hot
water heater the other day and I have
like one I don't know anything about
plumbing but my the the where the water
goes in the pipe we'll just say is
three-quarter inches and where it comes
out it's like a quarter inch and the guy
before even area to open a wall he goes
well I don't know who did that but that
is not up to code and he as a plumber
was saying that you know most plumbers
don't take the time to do it right so I
think in general we can you know listen
here's a deal I mean a few guys [ __ ]
[ __ ] on comedians I'll laugh about it
all [ __ ] day long I love it
comics [ __ ] on other comics I don't give
a [ __ ] I didn't realize how precious the
art of painting was a house how
sensitive people are until this guy here
[ __ ] you
you redheaded do-nothing [ __ ] by the way
you forgot the hyphen between do and
nothing just the way you missed that
corner when you're painting the house
you're sloppy [ __ ] alright stop bashing
my [ __ ] career this guy really comes
with soccer-mom energy I'm working 75
hour weeks to get my wife and kid
through this pandemic that has your
[ __ ] ass stuck at home look at this
[ __ ] guy he paints a house and all of
a sudden he thinks he can throw heads
oh you're a tough guy huh walking around
with the OshKosh B'gosh overalls let me
ask you this on your painter boots did
you write right and left so you'd put
them on correctly I'm coming right back
at you buddy it's your [ __ ] whining
about your [ __ ] work week just
because you people hire idiots doesn't
make all painters bad this this point
has already been made stop hiring
dumbass you [ __ ] morons I agree with
that take your mic out of your ass
hilarious and learn how to vet a
contractor you bald [ __ ]
once again body shaming me
I liked your podcast until last week
you're gonna take your paintbrushes and
go home you're gonna go out go cry in
your van hey good luck to you buddy all
the [ __ ] people that I have [ __ ] on
in this podcast all of these [ __ ]
people I've [ __ ] on you've had no
[ __ ] problem with it whatsoever and
all of a sudden I come around to you and
your little pedophile [ __ ] van with
your splotchy [ __ ] paint and your
[ __ ] nice head of hair right and all
of a sudden now you're gonna leave well
go ahead go ahead and [ __ ] leave you
know what yeah I'm gonna do you a favor
leave here I'm gonna look up I'm gonna
find a painting podcast how's that you
can listen to so you can feel like it's
a safe space house painting podcast here
we go I'm gonna give you the first one
podcast America's number nine I why the
[ __ ] is it oh my god this is just a wide
open market podcast for painters paint
talk 2016 what do we got here podcast
for painters why listen to a podcast
finding podcast podcast for painters
painting and decorating contractor's of
America paint Edie you might want to
listen to that one cuz Edie's like
education contractor SEO Pro
construction guide there you go buddy
there you go happy trails
I [ __ ] soccer-mom you look at you
[ __ ] getting you goddamn [ __ ]
painter panties in a bunch thinking that
I'm giving a [ __ ] that you're walking
away
and with your soggy [ __ ] Pater socks
squashes sloshing around your Red Wing
boots all right I work harder and deal
with more [ __ ] than you could ever
imagine
all right time out what do you know
about my life you don't even think you
think that's working 75 at 5 hours a
week is impressive to me
buddy just to remind you I do two
podcasts a week myself all right I then
do another one with Bert Kreischer I
also run a podcast network and within
the podcast network I produce stand-up
specials and TV shows and to do those I
have to go around town pitching those
things all right that's just one little
aspect then I also write produce and act
on an animated show called f is for
family okay I got to put out 10 episodes
do you know how long it takes to make 10
episodes of an animated show it takes
about ten and a half months and then it
comes out and then you go right back to
do it all over again
all right I also just finished a [ __ ]
movie script that I've been working on
for two [ __ ] years I'm also with
stand-up comedian and put out a stand-up
special every two [ __ ] years so [ __ ]
you and your 75 hour work week go [ __ ]
yourself I want you to go do your 75
hour work week in front of a bunch of
white chicks that are looking for you to
say one wrong thing at your job and then
end your career and cancel you so go
[ __ ] yourself 75 our [ __ ] work week
coloring in [ __ ] walls go [ __ ]
yourself
I am so sick of [ __ ] people thinking
that they have the hardest [ __ ] job
and oh do you paint houses in the United
States of America you don't I want you
to do right now sir I want you to look
down and look at that spare tire hanging
over your [ __ ] belt and realize that
90% of the world will never eat as much
food in their life than you eat in ten
[ __ ] years so [ __ ] you Jesus I am so
[ __ ] sick when the you know is
[ __ ] hilarious I like all of these
[ __ ] people you're working 75 hours a
week oh good for [ __ ] you to get my
wife and kid through this pandemic what
a [ __ ] hero what we're all [ __ ]
working everybody's working how many
hours work as a doctor working take a
[ __ ] joke you [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this
guy [ __ ] this guy all right he works
harder he has no idea like he thinks I'm
just sitting by a [ __ ] [ __ ] pool
right knock-knock jokes windows get
painted by the [ __ ] homeowners and
idiot nephews when you were too cheap to
hire a real contractor I run a business
play drums and sing for a band and still
have time to take care of my family
without complaining about [ __ ] that I
don't have any idea about time out time
out you just [ __ ] with [ __ ] all
over the entertainment business saying
that I don't do anything go [ __ ]
yourself
and then do it again you red fuzzy
[ __ ] it's plural for some reason
maybe he was just joking I don't know
why this is another thing everybody I am
[ __ ] over listening to how hard
people [ __ ] work let me ask you guys
a question how annoying was it when I
just told you how hard I work and I'd
even tell you how many hours I told you
how many months how annoying was that
okay just know that when you do that you
sound just as [ __ ] annoying oh my god
I have to bust my ass every week to take
care of my family who doesn't who
doesn't you know let me ask you this
painter you tell me what's you tell me
what in your [ __ ] career you go do
show you go shoot what is this Showtime
at the Apollo surviving that of being a
[ __ ] house painter go [ __ ] yourself
these [ __ ] this is visit my thing
about all of this [ __ ] the this is for
all you out there who are going to be
successful in life know this that no one
is gonna help you
you're gonna be all alone alright if it
involves going on the road you're gonna
get to beaten you're gonna intimately
know motel 6 super 8 and those are like
above the No Country for Old Men motels
that you're gonna stay in all right and
you're gonna do whatever it takes to get
there and you're gonna do the equivalent
of standing in a cafeteria of college
kids in the middle of the day who had no
idea that was gonna be a show and you're
gonna stand up there and [ __ ]
humiliate yourself and there's gonna be
nobody there to help you okay and if
your dream doesn't go doesn't come true
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] alright but
if it does come true then what's gonna
happen is everybody's gonna act like it
was given to you and you didn't work for
it and your life is just putting your
feet up and sitting courtside and
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] playing
grab-ass with people this is what I've
learned about super successful people
most of them have pools and very rarely
are they in them
[Laughter]